إنهم يتحدثون عن المعلومات التي
لديهم ولا نملك إطلاعًا عليها ، لذلك
لا نعرف حقًا أنهم قد أبدوا
آراء حول الثقة المنخفضة من
وزارة الطاقة والثقة المعتدلة على ما أعتقد
من مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ، لذلك
لا أعتقد  هناك
إجابة صحيحة وقابلة للتحقق حقًا لسؤالك ، إنه لا
يزال غير معروف في هذه
المرحلة بالذات ، هناك نظريتان
لأننا جميعًا على دراية الآن
بنظرية تسرب المختبر ، والآخر هو أنه
حدث طبيعي من انتشار الحيوانات
الشيء الوحيد هو أنه يتعين علينا أن نتحلى
بعقل متفتح حول هذا الأمر حتى يكون هناك
دليل قاطع على مدى أهمية
معرفتنا لمعرفة الأمر
جيدًا ، إنه أندرسون لأنك تريد
التأكد من أن أيًا من تلك
البدائل هو أننا نفعل أي شيء
يمكننا منع حدوث ذلك في
المستقبل لأننا شهدنا تفشي المرض
قبل أن أعني أن لدينا سارس cov1 والذي
ظهر بوضوح أنه ينتقل من الخفافيش إلى قطة
الزباد إلى الإنسان وإذا كان هناك
احتمال وهو بالتأكيد
لدينا '  إذا استبعدنا وجود
تسرب في المختبر ، فهناك أشياء يمكنك القيام بها
لمنع تكرار هذه الأشياء